comme vous le savez nous avons décidé de
travailler au premier semestre sur le
thème de la pornographie nous nous
pencherons à la fois sur le
fonctionnement et les pratiques de
l'industrie pornographique
les conditions de tournage les
représentations des femmes et des
sexualités véhiculés sur ainsi que la
rrq sur l'accès de plus en plus précoce
des mineurs aux contenus pornographiques
et ses conséquences en matière
d'éducation à la sexualité la presse
s'est récemment fait l'écho de graves
dérives dans le milieu pornographique
avec des pratiques de plus en plus
violentes et dégradantes et des mises en
examen pour viol de plusieurs acteurs et
producteurs les dérives qui nous ont
confortés dans notre choix de cette
thématique de travail nous sommes qu'à
deux sénatrices rapporteur pour mener
ses travaux alexandra borio fantin
laurence cohen et laurence rossignol que
j'ai aperçu à l'écran également et moi
même donc pour la bonne information de
toutes et tous je précise que cette
réunion fait l'objet d'un enregistrement
vidéo accessible en ce moment même sur
le site internet du sénat sur son compte
twitter puis en version originale
d'après les chiffres récents dont nous
disposons en dénombre en france
aujourd'hui 20 minutes conférence va
maintenant être enregistrés très bien
donc nous sommes enregistrés désormais
donc d'après les chiffres récents dont
nous pouvons disposer dont nous
disposons en deep on dénombre en france
aujourd'hui 20 millions de visiteurs
uniques de sites pornographiques par
mois en août 80 % des mineurs ont déjà
vu des contenus pornographiques et à 12
ans près d'un enfant sur trois a déjà
été exposée à de telles images c'est
précisément sur le sujet de l'accès des
mineurs aux sites pornographiques que
porte notre audition d'aujourd'hui nous
accueillons en effet carole bien aimé
baisse membre du collège de l'autorité
de régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle et numérique
l'art comme né le 1er janvier 2022 de la
faune fusion du cs a et de la haute
autorité pour la diffusion des oeuvres
et la protection des droits sur internet
hadopi madame bien aimé baisse ou vous
présidez au sein de l'art comme le
groupe le travail éducation protection
des publics et cohésion sociale vous
êtes à ce titre en charge du suivi du
dossier de l'accès des mineurs aux sites
pornographiques
peut-être pourriez-vous nous rappeler
dans un premier temps les compétences
historiques ce du csa en matière de
contrôle de l'accès des mineurs à la
pornographie lorsque ce contrôle
s'exerçait essentiellement sur la
diffusion de films pornographiques à la
télévision avant la diffusion de masse
de la pornographie sur internet en
matière de contrôle de l'interdiction
d'accès des mineurs à la pornographie
l'art comme exerce aujourd'hui des
compétences en amont et en aval en amour
il s'agit notamment de mener des actions
pour que les dispositifs de contrôle
parental soient mieux connus installé et
activé nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale ont d'ailleurs adopté la
semaine dernière une proposition de loi
visant à obliger les fabricants
d'appareils connectés à inclure un
contrôle parental gratuit et facile
d'utilisation en aval il s'agit
aujourd'hui de faire appliquer les
dispositions de la loi du 30 juillet
2020 qui grâce à un amendement de notre
collègue marie mercier oblige les sites
pornographiques à mettre en place des
systèmes efficaces de blocage de l'accès
aux mineurs la loi du 30 juillet 2020
autorise en effet le csa l'art comme
aujourd'hui à contrôler qu'un site a
bien mis en oeuvre une solution
technique satisfaisante qui va au-delà
de la simple déclaration d'âge en août
le président de l'autorité peut saisir
la justice pour obtenir le blocage
complet d'accès des sites qui aurait
ignoré son injonction cette procédure de
mise en demeure a été mise en oeuvre
pour la première fois en décembre
dernier lorsque le csa a demandé à cinq
sites de mettre en place un contrôle
dash plus robuste et plus fiables ces
cinq sites sont aujourd'hui menacés d'un
blocage judiciaire si aucune solution
technique satisfaisante n'est trouvée
pourriez-vous nous dire où en est
aujourd'hui la procédure et quels sont
vos échanges à ce sujet avec les cinq
sites concernés quels sont les obstacles
techniques et juridiques à la mise en
place de systèmes efficaces de
vérification d'âge et de blocage de
l'accès aux mineurs notre délai a sion a
auditionné la semaine dernière plusieurs
associations féministes engagées dans la
lutte contre la pornographie dont osez
le féminisme qui s'est d'ailleurs
constituée partie civile dans le procès
dit du porno français pour lequel on
recense aujourd'hui une cinquantaine de
victimes avec des plaintes pour viol
proxénétisme traite des êtres humains sa
porte-parole céline pic nous a indiqué
avoir fourni au csa une liste de 118
sites qui devraient pouvoir faire
l'objet d'une mise en demeure au même
titre que les cinq sites déjà visé par
votre autorité et dans l'accès aux
contenus devraient pouvoir être bloqué
conformément à la loi en vigueur quelles
seront les suites données par l'art
comme au signalement de ces 118 sites
pornographiques madame bien aimé baisse
je voulais sans plus tarder la parole et
je vous remercie vous êtes accompagné
au ce matin et vous allez nous présenter
les jeunes fans qui vous accompagnent ce
matin merci madame merci madame la
présidente
bonjour mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
effectivement je suis accompagné
d'alexandre amiel donc qui dirige au
sein de l'art comme et elle le faisait
déjà au sein du csa la département
protection des publics au sein duquel se
retrouvent la protection des mineurs
géraldine van heel qui dirige le
département cohésion sociale au sein
duquel on retrouve toutes les questions
relatives aux droits des femmes et
lucile petit qui est la directrice de
cette nouvelle direction dit plateforme
au sein du csa est aujourd'hui de l'art
comme don qu'elle suivrait toute la
régulation systémique du côté des des
plateformes donc vous le voyez nous
sommes venus en force pour vous montrer
effectivement la détermination du
conseil sur ces sujets de l'autorité
aujourd'hui et sans plus attendre donc
je vais vous présenter un petit peu
faire un petit rappel un petit rappel
historique de démission qui ont été les
nôtres au cours des années que l'autre
non poursuit aujourd'hui donc tout
d'abord concernant la les droits des
femmes ce qu'il faut appeler
effectivement c'est que l'autorité le
conseil à l'époque est engagée à la fois
sur une représentation
une juste représentation des femmes à
l'antenne donc elle chaque année elle
recense le nombre de femmes à l'antenne
des experts tels publie un rapport
annuel
rigaud fin chaque année et ce rapport en
fait c'est vrai que les choses ont
vraiment évolué et la loi en fait de
2014 nous a vraiment donné les moyens de
pouvoir faire ce recensement
indispensable puisque effectivement pour
pouvoir mesurer la progression il était
indispensable que les chaînes puissent
se faire un
s'auto évaluer et comptabiliser le
nombre de personnalités féminines à
l'antenne l'émission de du conseil est
donc de l'art comme ne s'arrête pas là
elle il s'agit pas uniquement de compter
le nombre de femmes à l'antenne il
s'agissait également de s'assurer que
les programmes audiovisuels ne véhicule
pas de stéréotypes
et aussi faste la promotion de la lutte
contre les violences à l'encontre des
femmes je rappelle tout tenté cette
mission parce qu'elle est évidemment
liée à celle qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui
donc je parlais de la loi de 2014 pour
l'égalité réelle entre les femmes et les
hommes il ya eu aussi la loi de 2017 qui
a donné compétence au conseil sur les
programmes publicitaires considérant qu
effectivement la publicité elle aussi
pouvaient participer
au fait de véhiculer des stéréotypes
sexistes
concernant la protection des mineurs
vous l'avez dit c'est une mission
historique du conseil
et de l'art comme c'est quelque chose de
si cette notion qui est très présente
également
dans le cadre de la directive et sema on
se rend compte que au niveau européen et
je crois qu au niveau international les
préoccupations sont les mêmes autant on
peut avoir des divergences sur des
sujets relatifs peut-être au soutien de
la création mais concernant la
protection des mineurs
honnêtement les problématiques sont les
mêmes partout c'est comment s'assurer
que les mineurs puissent continuer à
être protégé comme il l'était à la
télévision sur les plateformes
numériques
donc
pour rappeler la mission enfin les
originales si je puis dire en la matière
donc il fallait s'assurer dans le cas de
la régulation que les mineurs ne
subissent pas trop de pression
publicitaire que les programmes
participent à leur épanouissement
et à l'enrichissement intellectuel et
culturel
il s'agissait également de faire en
sorte que les mineurs ne soient pas
exposés à des images dites inapproprié
alors qu'est ce qu'on entend par
inapproprié on pense aux jeux d'argent à
la violence extrême violence est bien
évidemment à la pornographie
donc de ce point de vue là la
signalétique qui avait été développé par
le conseil
et qui est maintenant qui totalement
connues et qui que se sont réappropriés
les éditeurs puisque ce sont eux grâce
au comité de visionnage interne qu'il
décide d'apposer tel ou tel signalétique
et bien évidemment en allant plus loin
dès 2004
nous avons rédigé une recommandation qui
demandait effectivement aux éditeurs de
ne pas diffuser de programme pour nos
graphiques 20 2 diffusé par donc des
programmes dits pornographiques
uniquement la nuit donc entre minuit et
5 heures du matin deux avec un
verrouillage permanent des programmes
pornographiques au moyen d'un code
personnel
et une information régulière des abonnés
sur ce verrouillage donc ça c'est dans
le cadre d'une des recommandations de
2004 sachant que auparavant comme je le
dis on avait une signalétique bien connu
qui faisaient que effectivement un
mineur ne pouvait pas être exposée en
journée à des programmes d'une extrême
violence ou une pornographiques ensuite
la délibération donc du 20 décembre 2011
qui elle s'est impliquée aux services de
médias audiovisuels à la demande nous a
permis d'étendre ce dispositif de
verrouillage des programmes
pornographiques à ses services donc j'ai
dit c'est effectivement très important
c'est l'idée c'est de toujours c'est 2-2
stable at t est de faire en sorte que le
dispositif que l'on a mis en place à
l'origine puisse s'appliquer sur enfin
puisse adapter en fait aux différents
modes de consommation dont on sait
qu'ils sont maintenant en mobilité pour
la plupart et plus uniquement sur le
poste de télévision mais sur des
smartphones ou tablettes et avec un
visionnage qui est souvent solitaire
donc les parents ne sont pas forcément
là pour s'assurer que effectivement ce
que les jeunes regardent soit un contenu
approprié sans compter effectivement la
multiplication des écrans au sein des
foyers qui fait qu effectivement chaque
chaque membre du foyer à son
son appareil et peut effectivement se
retrouver isolée dans sa chambre à
regarder des contenus inappropriés
donc concernant
la mission de l'art comme c'est vrai que
nous au delà de enfin on entend toujours
la régulation de manière dont il ya le
la régulation stricte
le droit et met également l'incitation
donc c'est pour effectivement de ce
travail d'incitation de droit souple que
que l'on peut effectivement faire
évoluer les choses
donc en nous nous sommes mis
effectivement à promouvoir les outils de
contrôle parental
avec effectivement cette idée
qu évidemment nous était
fortement
incité par les membres de notre comité
d'experts du jeune public que nous avons
composé renforcer en 2017 considérant qu
effectivement avec le changement des
usages il était essentiel que l'on
puisse s'appuyer sur des experts et des
personnalités de la société civile donc
on est chercheur en neurosciences des
pédopsy
qui nous accompagnent régulièrement
effectivement l'outil de contrôle
parental est quelque chose sur lequel
nous avons commencé à travailler
en 2020 un protocole d'engagements pour
la prévention de l'exposition des
mineurs à la pornographie en ligne a été
signée par les pouvoirs publics les
associations et des acteurs économiques
du numérique
ce protocole d'engagement a été donc
piloté conjointement par l'art comme
donc par le csa l'époque et par l'art
comme aujourd'hui et l'arcep donc un
travail enfin vraiment en rendent très
bonne intelligence entre ces deux
autorités qui ont travaillé main dans la
main pour réaliser la plateforme que
vous connaissez je protège mon enfant
point gouv.fr
qui est donc un site qui à la fois
propose
des conseils aux parents sur la vie
affective
des mineurs en rappelant des chiffres
que vous avez rappelé mal à la
présidente
effectivement à l'âge de 12 ans
nombre de démineurs enfin des enfants de
moins de 12 ans ont été exposés ont déjà
été exposés à des images pornographiques
et également grâce à tous les opérateurs
dès sorte de tutoriel pour effectivement
installé ce que ce soit sur un
ordinateur ou un smartphone un outil de
contrôle parental puisque effectivement
en fonctions de l'outil que vous
utilisez de la marque et du logiciel les
outils ne sont pas les mêmes et c'est
vrai que cette profusion d'outils de
contrôle parental n'a pas ne permet pas
aux parents de pouvoir rapidement
s'approprier de ces outils
indispensables sachant que nous sommes
bien évidemment bien conscient que
cet outil ne suffit pas et que la
promotion et le dialogue est aussi
important
par ailleurs nous avons dans ce cadre
dans le cadre de ce protocole
d'engagements
conçu un baromètre qui nous a permis
d'évaluer le taux d'utilisation de ces
outils par les foyers français
donc mettons à jour de façon
trimestrielle
concernant le cadre juridique donc voilà
lâché t surplus sur les questions de
effectivement de deux
à la fois 2 de dialogue mais aussi de
recommandations là si vraiment on
s'attache au cadre juridique on se rend
compte qu'il a été vraiment renforcé
donc avec une modification du code pénal
donc notamment l'article
227-24
et vous l'avez dit madame la présidente
donc depuis la loi du 30 juillet
2020 le conseil donc le président du
conseil est aujourd'hui de l'art comme
peut effectivement saisir mettre en
demeure ces sites et saisir le juge si
si besoin
donc ses compétences
nous les mettons en oeuvre depuis la
parution du décret donc
relatifs à cette fois effectivement le
décret
est paru à l'automne dernier nous avions
été saisis comme vous l'avez dit par de
nombreuses associations
donc tout d'abord
nous avons effectivement été saisie par
des associations de protection de
l'enfance
et donc on a alors effectivement des
scellés les sites ont quinze jours pour
se mettre en conformité
nous avons procédé par ordre c'est à
dire que nous avons pris des saisines
qui nous avaient été communiquées le nom
des sites donc j'ai effectivement s'agit
s'agissait de pornhub
xhamster xvid et aux knicks 106 x tu
kiffes jackie et michel
tv et jacques et michel tv2
donc nous avons fait des constats
d'huissiers
parce qu'effectivement il était
important de réaliser de nombreux
constats de s'assurer que les
dispositifs n'était pas en place nous
sommes au stade où certains dont
certains sites ont considéré que avait
mis en place des outils
mais la loi effectivement de précise
bien qu'il faut que ces outils soient
efficaces donc à nous ensuite de nous
assurer par le biais de deux constats
d'huissier que ces outils
répondent bien à ce qui est demandé par
ailleurs dans le cadre de la loi
on a l'art comme peu adopté des lignes
directrices concernant donc la fiabilité
des procédés techniques mises en oeuvre
donc ces lignes directrices ont
d'énormes interprétative sans force
coercitive
donc ils n'ont pas vraiment d'impact sur
les exigences de conformité à la loi
répressive
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre et je
pense que c'est le cas
notamment dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le piratage des contenus
soient culturels ou sportifs c'est que
la notion de sites miroirs
elle est vraiment à prendre en compte
donc la protéger de la procédure de
l'article 22 23 peut être enclenchée
lorsqu'un site bloqué et rendu
accessible à partir d'une autre adresse
et que son contenu pornographique
demeurent accessibles sans procédés
techniques permettant de s'assurer que
les utilisateurs sont majeurs et ça
c'est très important parce qu'on sait
très bien que dans le ce cadre là
admettons que le juge décide
effectivement de faire bloquer un site
il arrive fréquemment comme je disais
dans le cadre du piratage qu'on voit
renaître un site sous une autre adresse
et ce en quelques heures d'où la
nécessité effectivement de et le
liquidateur l'a bien compris de
d'insérer cette notion de de lutte aussi
contre les sites miroirs
voilà je vous remercie et je suis
preneuse de vos questions
merci beaucoup pour ses propos
liminaires qui démontre aussi la
difficulté véritablement d'avancé sur
ces travaux puisque incite les
plateformes on essaye d'agir avec des
protocoles vous l'avez dit
ddd guide de bonne conduite mais ça va
pas être suffisant puisque
semble-t-il est évidemment
l'accès à ces sites l'accès à ces
plateformes n'est pas forcément une
problématique uniquement nationales et
qu'on doit trouver des moyens de lutter
à une plus grande échelle et on est au
niveau européen au niveau international
donc peut-être les rapporteurs ont-ils
dans un premier temps des questions
parce que il ya une affaire en cours
évidemment on n'est pas là pour
commenter une affaire en cours mais est
ce que cette affaire avec 50 50 victimes
comment imaginez vous aujourd'hui
l'avancé de 7 est-ce que ça va être
véritablement la possibilité cette
affaire de mettre en exergue une
problématique
évidente de la pornographie est ce que
ça va être la sphère finalement de la
pornographie qui va nous faire changer
au niveau le mythe ou de la pornographie
qu'à la française est ce que c'est une
première question et je t'invite bien
entendu les les rapporteurs dans un
premier temps laurence cohen laurence
rossignol et et alexandra s'ils avaient
bloqué au fond teint sial est également
connecté à intervenir et je suis
connecté très bien bonjour alexandra je
ne te vois pas l'écran je ne vois que
laurence rossignol pardon donc oui à une
première question donc c'est que il ya
cette affaire il ya énormément de
victimes les violences que ces victimes
ont fait moi n'y sont absolument
ignobles
incompréhensible on n'aurait pas imaginé
ces violences à cette échelle là puisque
on les a on a entendu l'association osez
le féminisme le nid la semaine dernière
notamment et comment comment rien
comment voyez vous cette affaire alors
ravi qu effectivement l'air comme est
compétent sur ce qui est diffusé et
parce qu'il se passe derrière la caméra
même si évidemment vous imaginez bien
que ce thème très sensible
aux témoignages
notamment remporté par la porte parole
céline pic nous avions organisé il ya
déjà deux ans une table ronde avec des
associations de défense des droits des
femmes et c'est une pique nous avait
déjà alerté
avec force de témoignage de la situation
effectivement de et des pratiques d'une
partie de cette industrie
pornographique
s'agissant de
doses et féministe mais justement on
nous avons été saisis
par cette association qui nous a
transmis comme vous l'avez dit une
centaine de sites qui ne serait pas
conforme donc alors ce moment même on
instruit donc cette saisine
est instruite donc on a souhaité faire
en fait c'était peut-être enfin attendre
déjà de voir ce qui se passait parce
qu'on retrouve certains des sites sur
lesquels nous avons été alertés par osez
le féminisme par qui se retrouvaient en
fait sur la liste des sites
sur lesquels vous avez saisi des
associations de défense des droits des
enfants de ce point de vue là ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que nous on
attend de savoir ce que le
juge va pouvoir et
fa le screen des skins va statuer à
l'issue effectivement des différentes
mises en demeure
ce qui nous a pas empêchés de déjà
commencé à faire des constats d'huissier
relatifs aux sites à la liste que nous a
fourni tenine pic et
poursuivre et ensuite si on considère
qu'il n'y a pas de mise en conformité
ont au bout de 15 jours
enfin la procédure habituelle que je
décrivais tout à l'heure et le juge
pourra de son côté faire bloquer le site
tout en ayant en tête évidemment
puisqu'on sait très bien que les sites
ces sites sont quand même opéré par des
organisations
qui sont très très bien organisée et qui
peuvent reproduire recréer dans l'eure
le même site donc mais cela dit
on est vraiment en train de fuir ses
demandes il ya une centaine de sites on
a commencé par cinq sites qui étaient
ceux qui faisaient le plus de volume
c'est un peu la façon dont on a résonné
c'était effectivement de prendre ce
qu'il y avait de plus de volume mais
concernant le traitement qui est fait à
ces femmes
à part peut-être le biais de l'article
40 de transmettre nous les
les dossiers sur lesquels on travaille
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas de compétence
sur ce qui se passe en dehors de deux
faces derrière derrière la caméra nous
c'est ce qui est diffusé qui sur lequel
nous sommes compétents
et ça n'a pas changé avec la création de
la com
merci beaucoup pour cette première
réponse moi ce que je trouve
évidemment on a l'impression c'est david
contre goliath parce que on parle
d'association qui saisissent qui vous
saisissent et de l'art comme et à côté
de ça on a une véritable industrie
d'organisation qui est très bien
positionné organisée donc la première
chose qu'on va devoir se poser nous à la
déléguée délégation c'est de quoi
peut-être at-on besoin comme structure
pour enfin réussir à lutter parce qu'on
a bien vu la semaine dernière les
associations elles ont des petits moyens
je passe là tout de suite la parole à
notre collègue et rapporteur laurence
rossignol et ensuite la rapporteure
laurence cohen
oui bonjour chers collègues bonjour
carole bien-aimée g et de gestion
anciens à poser dans certaines ont été
justement élaboré avec l'association
osez le féminisme et avec céline pitié
donc je voulais transmet même si vous
avez déjà donné des éléments réponse à
la première question c'est pourquoi le
csa la com
saisi par le tribunal administratif pour
faire ordonner le blocage du site et
pourquoi
les astuces pour l action des
associations et
préalable ou même le plus est le plus
offensive que celle du csa en sachant
que les associations bout de moyens
pouvoir pas de moyens alors que l'art
comme on a quand même davantage ça
c'était la première question la deuxième
question elle concerne l'action du délai
entre le moment où le lin site illégal
appareils et ce blocage du site avec une
inquiétude mais bien évoquer avec les
sites miroirs c'est que si les délais
sont trop longs
là
les second et crée immédiatement un site
miroir est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut recommencer à zéro toutes les
procédures avec le site le site miroir
enfin ma troisième question c'est
concerne plus particulièrement est ce
que vous observez dans votre action que
il vous manque soit des dispositifs
techniquement efficace que vous n'auriez
pas soit des bases légales
supplémentaires pour être plus efficace
merci chers collègues je vous laisse
répondre d'accord je pensais qu'il y
avait une série jamais mais je pense
qu'on va prendre les questions petit à
pied des réponses puisque vos réponses
pour inspirer peut-être d'autres
questions
alors merci beaucoup madame la
rapporteure madame la sénatrice donc jeu
alors
vous dire qu'effectivement nous on suit
la procédure vous l'avez rappelé donc on
nous auto saisi son où nous sommes
saisis par ailleurs par des associations
c'est vrai que là dans le cas précis les
associations dans un même saisi avant
même la parution du décret donc
effectivement ça peut laisser penser que
finalement on a attendu d'être saisis
avant de se mettre en action mais c'est
pas forcément le cas on avait bien en
tête de toute façon les sites sur
lesquels nous avons été saisis ensuite
donc c'est le tribunal
judiciaire et pas administrative qui est
compétent peut être pour le préciser et
enfin concernant les moyens
alors effectivement les associations des
moyens très faible il faut il faut quand
même savoir que notre direction des
plateformes
enfin on est quasiment à moyens
constants donc les choses vont changer
par la suite mais nos moyens sur le
sujet même si notre détermination est
entière
reste quand même limité même si
aujourd'hui il ya une urgence et vous
l'avez dit ce qu'on constate malgré tout
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de sociétés qui
réfléchissent à des modèles
d'outils de boue de dispositif de
vérification d'âge efficace
donc on a eu plusieurs nous
démonstration en échange avec la cnil
l'ansi
et les pouvoirs publics parce que je
pense qu'effectivement la solution elle
va venir de là c'est à dire de trouver à
un système
jusqu'ici nous les démonstrations que
certains sites avaient pu nous faire on
est en train de vérifier mais ça ne
semble pas forcément répondre
à tous les critères
il ya effectivement un besoin de
développer des solutions donc il ya
certaines solutions qui existent au
royaume uni au niveau européen comme je
voulais dit il ya plusieurs choses qui
se développe il faut maintenant les
mettre en place il faut que les sites
d'essai réapproprie on a eu une ou on
nous a fait plusieurs démonstrations
certaines étaient assez convaincante et
je crois que certains sites
pornographiques ont pris contact avec
cette société où l' inverse pour
justement pouvoir commencer à les
installer et se mettre en conformité
sur la durée alors la procédure elle est
effectivement c'était un délai de quinze
jours qu'on doit appartement vous mettez
en demeure vous devez laisser quinze
jours aussi pour montrer que pour leur
permettre de se mettre en conformité ou
nous prouver que lee le sont déjà donc
ça prend un peu de temps
même si qu'un jour c'est quand même
c'est assez rapide et ont pris enfin
pour pouvoir
nous permettre enfin et permettre au
président de l'art comme de saisir le
président du tribunal judiciaire de
paris
aux fins d'ordonner le blocage
il faut effectivement qu'on s'appuie sur
des constats d'huissier solide sinon on
peut effectivement se retrouver
à ce que finalement la démarche
ne sois pas
concluante donc je comprends moi là la
démarche de nausée le féminisme et je
pense que sans elle
je crois que ce reportage n'existerait
pas et sans leurs alertes
et vraiment je pense qu'elles ont fait
un travail remarquable
maintenant c'est vrai que l'outil il est
celui qu'on connaît
et je pense que il doit aussi
au niveau via l'outil effectivement le
cadre juridique mais il ya je pense le
cadre technique qui lui doit aussi être
développées renforcer et l'art comme
effectivement n'a pas vocation à en plus
à créer effectivement cet outil en
revanche nous sommes contactés
régulièrement jours lady depuis
maintenant quelques mois il ya des
solutions qui nous paraissent
aujourd'hui pouvoir
répondre
à cette problématique est donc j'espère
vraiment que les sites pour s'en emparer
après il ya aura toujours moyen de
contourner mais honnêtement si déjà tous
les sites s'équipent je pense qu'on aura
vraiment fait
une bonne partie du chemin
merci beaucoup je cède la parole à la
rapporteure laurence cohen pour moi qui
ai pas en présence à
bercy mais en ciel bonjour là bonjour à
toutes et à tous et merci pour ce
introduction en jeu
et je vous prie d'excuser mon retard y
ait eu quelques problèmes techniques
dans le rer pour tout de raconter mais
le sage en vous écoutant et en écoutant
vos réponses
j'ai le sentiment que il ya il manque un
outil parce que en fait vous nous
répondez
et vous êtes dans le cadre de votre
mission il n'ya pas j'ai pas de vous
nous répondez en terme de
deux cadres très précis d'une certaine
technicité et nous on a lu des
reportages on en a vu on a reçu les
associations osez le féminisme le ni les
effrontés on a pu entendre aussi un
certain nombre d'avocats et on est face
à
de la prostitution de l' esclavage enfin
des choses absolument abominable
et du coup il ya un décalage
parce que enfin qu'est ce que ça veut
dire finalement mettre un site en
conformité je n'arrive pas à saisir
cette notion parce qu'il ya les
violences de l'autre côté de la caméra
donc j'aime bien entendu que vous vous
n'intervenez pas de l'autre côté de la
caméra mais alors
que fait-on des conséquences de ce
visionnage puisque nous avons vu que ces
violences terribles extrêmes ont des
conséquences sur les femmes et les
hommes qui regardent ces films sans
parler des mineurs qui les regarde c'est
à dire que sa structure un rapport
à l'autre qui est absolument
épouvantable rapports de domination de
violence etc et donc je ne comprends pas
cette histoire de mise en conformité et
du coup si vous voulez je me dis si on
reste que dans ce cadre là
pardonnez-moi mais les organisations qui
tire beaucoup d'argent de sept de ses de
ses productions en beaux jours devant
elle parce que
je vois pas donc ça c'est ma première
question deuxième question est ce que
quand même dans le cadre de votre de
votre mission qui est quand même
extrêmement limité me semble-t-il inde
extérieurement est-ce que vous avez la
possibilité aussi d'avoir un soutien un
point d'appui avec
ceux qui
mènent les enquêtes la gendarmerie etc
est-ce que vous pouvez avoir des
auditions est ce que vous pouvez avoir
des soutiens et ma troisième question
c'est que
vous qui êtes un peu au coeur là dans un
certain nombre d'affaires à instruire
quelle solution
parce que parce que là j'ai un peu
l'impression que
enfin c'est très très limitées quoi je
donc soit il faut élargir vos missions
pour le dire plus plus directe soit il
faut créer un autre organisme avec des
missions beaucoup plus
directive mais dans l'état la
voilà c'est insuffisant
de mon point de vue voilà mais je ne
remet pas du tout en cause les le
travail que vous faites bien évidemment
c'est après ce qui vous est demandée oui
voilà j'essaie alors que nous la
délégation on a aussi besoin de faire
des recommandations qui vont être utiles
voilà donc merci davance merci beaucoup
à 91 inscrits alors peut-être rappeler
enfin je ne vais pas fait mais nous
étions le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel nous sommes aujourd'hui
l'autorité de régulation la
communication audiovisuelle et numérique
donc nous sommes compétents sur les
contenus audiovisuels et numériques
nous ne sommes pas compétents sur la
chaîne de fabrication de ces contenus
nous ne sommes pas compétents sur
les entreprises sur ce qui se passe au
sein de ces entreprises sur les
recrutements sur la manière dont sont
traités les personnes au sein de ces
entreprises donc nous ne sommes pas
compétents c'est donc c'est des
questions qui est des préconisations qui
sont les vôtres et je les comprends et
je pourrais même vous dire que je les
partage mais nous ne sommes pas
compétents c'est à dire que ce sont il
faut s'adresser aux tribunaux
l'art comme n'est pas compétente sur les
questions l'art comme son travail et sa
mission confiée par le législateur c'est
de mettre en conformité des sites
pornographiques c'est-à-dire de
s'assurer que ces sites pornographiques
ne sont pas accessibles aux mineurs donc
notre problématique à l'art comme est
celle là c'est de s'assurer que les
sites pornographiques ne soit pas
accessible aux mineurs c'est notre c'est
la seule mission qui soit la nôtre est
effectivement pas ce que vous décrivez
nous sommes alors au sein nous ne sommes
pas compétents je sais pas si on le
regrette et je pense que il ya d'autres
autorités qui le sont et il faut je
pense objectivement je me reconnaître
dans le cadre de cette mission mais sont
prévues échanger avec elle mais notre
munitions elle est celle ci donc c'est
pour ça que ya peut-être un
malentendu
sur ce que nous sommes et une autre
compétence et
donc jusqu'ici comme je le disais
jusqu'à la loi du 30 juillet 2020 notre
compétence s exerçait sur les médias
classiques donc la télévision
la radio et services de mme eliane
rattrapage
cette loi de 2020 elle est souhaité nous
donner compétence est donné compétence
au président de dollars comme pour faire
en sorte effectivement que ces sites ne
soit pas accès ce prono graphique ne
soit pas accessible aux mineurs donc il
s'agit même pas ni d'interdire la fin de
graphie il s'agit de faire en sorte de
protéger les mineurs et de faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas accès pour
pouvoir ensuite s'épanouir
voilà pleinement et préserver leurs
droits à l'innocence
merci madame bien-aimée pour ses
premières réponses alors c'est vrai que
vous lui dites votre travail c'est de
faire que ces sites ne soit pas
accessible à des mineurs que ce soit sur
le numérique sur l'audiovisuel la seule
chose c'est que déjà pour cette mission
nous au sein de la délégation on a
l'impression quand même si on se limite
avec à cette question ce matin que cette
mission n'est pas remplie aujourd'hui
donc est-ce que vous avez les moyens de
répondre à cette mission si vous ne les
avez pas tienne quels moyens
souhaitez-vous de quels moyens souhaitez
vous disposez pour remplir cette mission
d'accessibilité des mineurs
aux sites pornos qui héberge du porno et
donc l'accès des mineurs à la fois sur
la télévision est également sur le média
sur le numérique je vais passer j'ai
cette première question de gouverner si
je vais passer la parole à ceux qui leur
demandent et c'est bruno belin et
ensuite ce sera dominique les rien je
n'ai pas vu que alexandre voilà
donc je vais essayer d d'abord laurence
rossignol qui souhaite reprendre la
parole
merci madame la présidente on comprend
bien que le csa ne vous elle ne peut
agir que dans le cadre de ses
compétences et que si les autres
passaient il y aurait des risques de la
peine de nullité des procédures que
quelqu'un sait s engagerait que ce
serait long contre productif
pour autant il ya une question qui quand
même pour moi de me sais comment ça se
fait qu'il a fallu que ce soit des
associations qui enclenche face aux
brevets qui ont clanche des procédures
qu'ils fassent des signalements qui vous
importe à vous des
signalements sur des cibles
supplémentaires pourquoi le csa n'est
pas en amont des associations et la
deuxième question vous est posée mais à
laquelle vous avez pas répondu
est ce que pensait que vous manquez de
base légale pas simplement de base
technique va pas seulement d'outils
techniques est ce que vous manquez une
base légale pour
atteindre l'objectif non parce que là
que la loi vous fixe mais que l'esprit
de la loi de coûts fixes et en fait
juste vérifier une chose l'alouette 2014
sur l'égalité réelle entre les femmes et
les hommes vous donne compétence pour
étudier les la place des femmes dans
l'audiovisuel et intervenir aussi et
faire de nous en heure elle a été
étendue à la publicité mais juste une
vérification technique il est clair que
vous n'avez pas la compétence sur les
contenus sur le net c'est juste une
c'était les vérifications
[Musique]
merci
merci cher lance je vous laisse
peut-être répondre accord à la fois ces
deux questions auprès je passerai la
parole à bruno belin et de nigériens qui
leur demandait alors je réponds question
est d'abord voilà merci le sentiment
effectivement qu'on peut être qu'on a
tardé et que voit un peu de sentiment
qu'on n'est pas assez efficace
juste rappelé la chronologie la loi
effectivement été a été votée en juillet
2020 mais le décret n'a été publié que
le 7 octobre 2021 et donc sans décret on
n'a aucune on n'avait aucune possibilité
donc il a fallu effectivement une
notification
au niveau européen enfin bon bref c'est
donc le décret a été publié le 7 octobre
alors on peut le regretter effectivement
les îles et les associations nous avait
saisi bien avant ensuite c'est vrai que
nous on allait aussi la capacité de nous
auto saisie donc à partir du moment où
on a une nouvelle compétence
l'art comme du fait de ses nouvelles
compétences peut tout à fait se dire je
m'occupe de tel ou tel site donc sur les
délais honnêtement on est fin janvier le
décret qui est publique et publié le 7
octobre une liste de sites qui nous est
communiquée des constats d'huissiers qui
doivent être faits parce que s'ils sont
mal faits là aussi on risque une nullité
ou le fait de nous
dégoûté laissé quinze jours au site pour
se mettre en conformité je trouve qu'on
est plutôt dans les délais
mais je comprends du fait de l'urgence
que ce sentiment que vous ayez ce
sentiment que les choses n'aillent pas
assez vite
et sachant qu'en plus les associations
elles ont aussi la capacité
d'agir devant la justice mais sur la
base de l'article du code pénal que je
citais tout à l'heure le 200
22-24 donc là aussi sur les autorités
compétentes je crois qu'il faut aussi
l'art comme ne peuvent ne pourra pas
tout faire c'est une évidence même si ça
reste de l'audiovisuel et des médias
on est compétent que sur cette
limitation d'accès aux mineurs
concernant la question de madame le
rossignol
là sur la compétence sur le net alors le
peu d'êtres préciser les choses nous
sommes compétents donc comme je disais
sur les sma ce qu'on appelle les smad du
fait de la vie active et schémas mais
notre compétence elle n'est pas
forcément la même sur les médias l'inr
sûr que sur le net je prends un exemple
sur toutes nos compétences liées à la
déontologie
et à l'information à l'honnêteté
d'information si on va sur le net la loi
de 2018 elle nous donne un pouvoir
systémique c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
contenue par contenu nous devons nous
assurer que les plateformes ont mis en
place des outils pour lutter contre la
désinformation
alors que quand on est sur des médias
r on est convenus par contenu séquence
par séquence émissions par émission où
là on apprécie le contenu le travail
fait par tel ou tel journaliste pour
s'assurer que telle ou telle émission ne
véhicule pas de la désinformation donc
sur le linéaire on est sur du contenu
par contenu et sur les plates formes on
est sur une régulation systémique
et effectivement c'est différent je fais
à prendre par exemple les discours
notre compétence relative au discours de
haine qui elle aussi est nouvelle ni à
la loi sur les principes républicains
dans le cas de définitivement des médias
l'inr on va apprécier chaque émission
jacques ont tenu les propos qui sont
tenus qui pourrait amener à des
discriminations
et sur les discours de haine là aussi on
est sur une appréciation systémique avec
une demande une exigence qui est faite
aux plateformes de mettre en place des
outils pour ne pas permettre au discours
de haine de publier sur le sur leur
plateforme effectivement du fait de la
du nombre du volume de contenu contre
sur le numérique le législateur que vous
êtes a considéré qu effectivement il
fallait peut-être apprécié les choses de
manière plus systémique et pas contenue
par contenu
merci pour ces réponses bruno belin
notre collecte et en présentiel merci
madame la présidente merci madame pour
votre présentation mais je vais revenir
un petit peu
sur intervention qui a fait notre
collègue laurent soit guen serre sur
fondamental de ce qui nous réunit ce
matin bien compris que l'art comme c'est
ce qui se passe avant c'est à dire non
pas derrière la caméra mais
effectivement dans l'offre
du contenu moi j'ai le sentiment d'abord
quand on parle de mise en conformité ça
veut dire abandonnez on avalise ce qui a
peut-être qu'on trouve une définition
j'ai l'impression aussi que vous courez
après la tempête on sait ça nous a été
dit la semaine dernière ça a été redit
par la présidente ce matin 20 millions
de vues mensuelles on nous a parlé pour
certains sites de milliards de dollars
de chiffre d'affaires vous imaginez bien
que c'est une vraie mafia qui n'a qu'une
canne intéressés de contourner ou une
s'adapter aux lois en tout cas j'ai
l'impression que nous on va faire un
nous collectif puisque vous agissez dans
un cadre légal et nous sommes là pour
veiller à ce cadre légal nous courons
après la tempête est ce qu'il n'ya pas
quelque chose de beaucoup plus simple
parce qu'aujourd'hui se connecter sur un
site pornographique est excessivement
simple avait ou plus de 18 ans oui point
il ya pas d'autres vérifications si je
veux faire un simple virement d'un
simple compte en banque que je vais
avoir un code d'accès qu pour lesquelles
je me serais inscrits pour lequel on va
me donner un numéro fort tête de
portable sur lequel j'aurai un code
confidentiel qui me permettra de croiser
de sécuriser cette information est ce
qu'il ya pas un moyen technique je n'y
connais rien partez du principe que je
n'y connais rien mais je constate
aujourd'hui avec un outil que nous
utilisons tous les jours qui s'appelle
cidep pour les informations liées à la
pandémie on peut donner des informations
confidentielles sécurisé d'un site
internet sur lequel on sait qu à qui on
a affaire avec lesquels on peut croiser
avec un simple numéro de portable donc
ce qui est faisable sur les informations
hautement sécurisé puisqu'elle concerne
votre santé pourquoi on n'arrive pas
faire avec jackie et michel ou je ne
sais qu autant le dire clairement donné
on s'est bien ça a été redit par
laurence on en a tous conscience que ça
génère c'est cette tranche d'âge dans
l'eau de l'essence une image qui
finalement se résume par de la violence
derrière pointent donc je crois qu'il
faut qu'on trouve une solution technique
qu'on y met
l'anc rue qu'il faut encre avec 1,1 à
pour accrocher
fondamentalement et faire barrage à cet
accès et je suis convaincu que c'est
très en amont de la construction qu'il
faut intervenir
est-ce possible je ne sais pas je vous
livre cette réflexion sur la facilité de
l'accessible de l'accessibilité à un
site
alors merci monsieur le sénateur pour
cette question c'est évidemment c'est le
constat qu'ont que nous faisons depuis
depuis très longtemps sur la
facilité d'accès à ces sites est encore
là vous parlez de sites sur lesquels on
vous demande si vous avez 18 ans il y en
a beaucoup où on vous le demande pas il
ya parfois des bandes annonces que vous
recevez alors que vous n'avez pas
sollicité vous
on en est extrêmement conscient et
effectivement de voir arriver cet
article 23 ans cette voie que 2021 est
effectivement une étape importante pour
permettre d'endiguer ce fléau comme on
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure voilà les
mineurs de moins de 12 ans sont exposés
à ces contenus de plus en plus tôt il
c'est un impact réel sur leur
développement même sur la société et
qu'elles sont veut comme saucisses et on
est tous d'accord là-dessus cannes mais
on trouve les chiffres on les nous les
connaissons nous avons construit avec co
construit avec l'arcep la fédération
française des télécoms tous les
signataires du protocole d'engagements
de lutte contre l'exposition des mineurs
à la pornographie
ce site web justement pour tenter de
commencer à avoir un outil pour endiguer
ce fléau donc avec ce site c'est ces
outils cet outil de contrôle parental
pour lequel on insiste qu'il est aussi
indispensable d'être installé sur tous
les outils des foyers mais concernant
les moyens qui sont les nôtres comme
jusqu'alors applets et
on lit une autorité administrative
indépendante on applique à la loi donc
on ne peut pas
agi en dehors du cadre qui nous est fixé
c'est en amont à et on a des moyens qui
sont les nôtres qui sont
en afrique d'abord une liberté de
communiquer une loi de liberté de
communiquer et donc on ne s'inscrit
absolument pas dans une interdiction ou
une censure
notre là ce qui nous est demandé donc de
façon générale et là sur ce point précis
il nous est demandé uniquement de
veiller à ce que les mineurs n'est pas
accès à ces sites sur leur nombre on n'a
aucun aucun pouvoir c'est à dire qu' on
n'est pas compétent sur le nombre de
sites qui existent qui secret ou de
sites illicites et donc c'est pour ça
que honnêtement la solution il faut
s'appuyer sur tous les outils dont il ya
cet article mais il ya aussi le code
pénal il ya les tribunaux il ya la
brigade des mineurs qui travaillent les
forces de l'ordre c'est un travail qui
façonnable à la prostitution il ya un
enterrement un groupe de travail
auquel nous avons participé justement la
prostitution des mineurs notamment grâce
à des outils en ligne qui permet
effectivement de nombreux mineurs de se
prostituer
on est conscient de cela mais
effectivement les compétences qui sont
les nôtres elles sont limitées et sur la
mise en conformité m'a effectivement
c'est ça peut paraître
inappropriés comme terme
de considérer qu'on met en conformité un
site pornographique mais
un double verrouillage c'est à dire
non mais alors justement donc il ya un
avis enfin la cnil a rendu un avis très
important il ya aussi qu'est-ce qu'on
fait du traitement qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait des données vous l'avez dit
sont des sites qui sont opérés souvent
par des entreprises qui sont
mafieuse on peut on peut le lire donc
c'est les données les données des
personnes les données des personnes qui
vont sur ces sites
est ce qu'on souhaite que les données
des bars des utilisateurs soient captés
par ces sites dont on ne sait d'ailleurs
pas où ils sont hébergés dont il ya
toute la question des données d'où la
difficulté de développer un outil qui
répondent en fait à tous les critères
qui soit à la fois de répondre aux
critères nous qui nous importe art comme
de protéger les mineurs et de ne pas
rendre accessible un site mais aussi de
la question des données
donc quand effectivement les procès ce
coup-ci ce que vous décrivez ils sont
très intéressants mais ça s'inscrit dans
des cadres légaux ça s'inscrit dans le
cadre de santé avec c'est comme les
données qui sont donnés dans le cadre de
vos documents d'identité on sait qu'ils
se trouvent derrière là on a affaire à
des sites qui sont pas forcément
hébergé en france et dont et comme vous
l'avez dit qu'ils sont parfois des
entreprises mafieuses donc la question
des données et elle doit être prise en
compte et comme je le disais nous avons
eu plusieurs sociétés développent à
l'heure actuelle des outils
qui sont
honnêtement nous qui nous ont convaincus
donc
ils sont en train maintenant
d'échanger avec des sites
pornographiques pour pouvoir
intégrer ses outils dans le cadre de ces
sites est pardonné ou encore pour ses
thermes et se mettre en conformité avec
ce qui est demandé par cette loi
donc on est au début du processus c'est
pour ça que je rappelais l'heureux
ce que j'entends dans votre réponse sam
c'est surtout que vous dites que il ya
un travail qui est en cours d'être fait
je ne connais pas vraiment ce qu'henri
ait travaillé que nous on sera très
attentifs avoir effectivement quelle est
la production de ce travail de
verrouillage entente et j'emploie
peut-être pas le bon terme mais au moins
il est la mairie dès le générique et le
monde le comprenne parce que je crois
que
de faire en sorte qu'ils aient vraiment
des barbelés
pour empêcher l'accès à de très jeunes
enfants à ce type de site est
essentielle le haut de ce qui se passe
derrière la caméra on s'y intéressera
parce que ça relève peut-être des
contrats de travail mais une autre en
tenue de notre organisation est
effectivement pas de l'art comme dans
tout cas sur l'accès à l'information
je pense que c'est dans le dans les
compétences de la com merci madame m en
tout cas merci mais vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur c'est d'ailleurs
notre mission mais c'est ce sur quoi
nous travaillons c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que nous
voilà les mises en demeure que nous
avons faits le prouvent on va continuer
on a cette liste de plus de 100 sites
nous allons continuer et surtout
participer en attendant à tout ce
travail pédagogique que nous on vient ce
site je protège mon enfant point gouv.fr
de l'autre côté de et d'échanger avec
toutes les entreprises qui sont en train
de créer des outils ou qui ont déjà créé
pour leur permettre de que ces outils de
contrôle d'âge soit mis en place sur un
maximum de sites c'était vraiment ce sur
quoi nous travaillons actuellement donc
je moi j'entends votre impatience et
frustrations et parce que c'est un sujet
d'une extrême importance
car il concerne effectivement nos jeunes
et je pense honnêtement que
voilà avec un décret publié en octobre
nous sommes en janvier et nous sommes
qu'aux débuts de
voilà et sachant qu'on a
mais vous faites bien et puis de toute
façon dans le cadre du questionnaire
quand vous avez transmis
madame la présidente on pourra vous
répondre aussi par écrit pour apporter
des précisions
supplémentaires
merci beaucoup je vais immédiatement
passé à la parole à notre rapporteur qui
est avant de me lever rien qui est en
visio avec nous et je possède la parole
alexandra voilà on te voit désormais
alexandra donc tu as la parole merci
merci madame la présidente
bonjour madame et bonjour à tous j'ai un
certain nombre d'interrogations
auxquelles nous avait déjà répondu dont
je veux juste rebondir aux photos de mon
collègue
[Musique]
sur l'éducation des parents par des
enfants
donc je sais ça se fait donner
l'objectif de renforcer son soutien
quant à l'effet numérique ma question
est la suivante comment mesure-t-on
l'efficacité des tutoriels qui sont
destinés aux parents pour mieux protéger
leurs enfants des contenus choquants et
clients c'est fait et je voulais me
paraît donc justement la fréquentation
plateforme vous venez d'en parler mais
je protège mon enfant de la pornographie
selon vous est elle bonne cliente
avez-vous d'ailleurs envisagé de
déployer une stratégie communication
pour améliorer sa notoriété de son
utilisation c'est vrai que je suis
découvert dans le cadre de cette mission
et dans
maman je la communication n'était pas
arrivée jusqu'à voir notre billet dont
je vais interroger sur sa carte immense
mais
merci puis on va te prendre la question
de dominique vais rien dans la foulée
puisque je
l'avais d'ores et déjà annoncés
problème merci beaucoup la présidente je
voudrais continuer sur la mission de
l'art comme
donc si j'ai bien compris tant que c'est
à la télé vous vous intéressez aux
contenus d'excès sur internet le contenu
n'est plus intéressant c'est simplement
le système et vous veillez à ce que la
plateforme sur laquelle on va mais les
verrous et s'auto régulent y compris sur
les contenus mais lorsque les contenus
parce qu on est bien d'accord la
pornographie n'est pas interdite donc il
n'y a pas à censurer la pornographie
tant qu'elle n'est pas interdite mais
lorsque le contenu
est explicitement un viol lorsque le
contenu est explicitement un appel
raciste
ou à la haine raciale lorsque ces
contenus sont donc indépendamment de
l'activité qui est la pornographie des
choses qui sont totalement
répréhensibles
est ce que l'art comme à une mission ou
pas ou est ce que c'est forcément le
juge et dans ces cas là qui peut saisir
le juge et est-ce qu'on peut ne faire
interdire que certaines vidéos sur
l'ensemble d'un site
et si si j'avais juste une autre
question qui était au top de quelle
année parce que nous c'est on est
d'accord c'est juillet 2020 et donc le
csssrn octobre 21 degrés le décret est
est ce que vous savez pourquoi un tel
délai a été nécessaire pour signer un
papier alors cher dominique je pense que
cette question est valable sur un
certain nombre de sujets les décrets
l'appliquent et comme l'a justement
rappelé notre collègue bruno belin nous
sommes aussi là pour vérifier vérifier
l'application de la loi et sa mise en
oeuvre et la promulgation des décrets et
souvent quelque chose qui arrive très
très en retard je ne suis absolument pas
surprise c'est moi on a envie que ça
passe plus le décret arrive loin
longtemps après c'est d'où la question
mais c'est une vraie problématique est
une vraie question
mais je suis pas persuadé que madame
bien aimé fils répondre aux délais c'est
pour ça que je me suis permis de faire
ce commentaire merci merci madame hadary
a dégoûté je sache et qu'on était très
très impatient de delamare ce décret
donc
alors madame pour vous répondre tout
d'abord donc sur l'éducation aux médias
l'éducation effectivement qui peut être
faite aux parents elle nous est
effectivement apparu essentiel parce que
beaucoup de parents n'ont pas du tout
conscience de ce problème c'est à dire
que les études qu'on a pu mener nous de
notre côté avait montré que souvent les
parents étaient préoccupés par le temps
d'écran le temps passé mais sans
forcément aller jusqu'à qu'est-ce qui
regardait
il considérant que les enfants était bon
ce soit responsable ou raisonnable et
qu'il savait
il n'y avait pas de problème d'où la
nécessité effectivement de l'heure sur
ce site de leur expliquer à la fois
comment on a installé un petit contrôle
parental en fonction de chaque outil de
chaque marque etc mais aussi de les
informer sur la vie affective et sur la
sexualité des adolescents parce
qu'effectivement le
c'est un sujet qui reste compliqué à
aborder au sein des familles et de ce
point de vue là d'encourager peut-être
le dialogue donc les tutoriels que nous
avons mis en place on les a évidemment à
chaque fois élaboré avec des
pédopsychiatres des
professionnels de l'enfance voilà pour
vous répondre mais c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet important
sur lequel
on a souhaité
insister notamment sur le lait ducation
et sur la communication autour de la vie
affective les jeunes concernant la
notoriété de ce site alors comme je les
dis aux mesures de façon trimestrielle
effectivement les connexions et le
nombre de visites donc on pourra vous
transmettre les chiffres dans le cadre
de du questionnaire
vous l'avez vous avez raison ce site
manque de notoriété donc on a fait en
sorte
pendre au début de l'été qu'il soit
mieux référencé sur les moteurs de
recherche quant aux google et autres de
les faire remonter effectivement quand
on recherche ont fait une recherche
relative à la protection de l'enfance
nous avons également mais le site
remporté un vrai succès je tiens à le
dire c'est vrai que ça a été long à
démarrer mais le site remporte un vrai
succès et d'ailleurs on a décidé de
l'étendre
à d'autres questions que la pornographie
à en faire une sur deux sites référents
sur de protection des mineurs puisque à
la base il était dédiée que la question
de l'exposition à la pornographie
sur la notoriété dont claquant des
campagnes
nous réfléchissons avec le comité de
pilotage pour effectivement peut-être
réalisé une campagne
est-ce que ça devrait passer par une
campagne de santé publique
voilà plusieurs pistes sont à l'étude
mais c'est une évidence madame la
sénatrice que qu'il faut promouvoir cet
outil pédagogique qui
monsieur le sénateur ne permettra pas
forcément de réduire le nombre de sites
mais au moins d'alerté et de faire en
sorte que les parents soient plus au
fait et je lis les parents mais aussi
tout le personnel encadrant
de ces questions
s'agissant alors de notre
mission
pour répondre à votre question à la
sénatrice
je crois important de alors peut-être
qu'effectivement j'ai
essayé de simplifier en expliquant un
peu quel était notre rôle sur le
numérique est en nous attachant à la
dimension systémique de la régulation
mais peut-être évidemment que ces
contenus sont problématiques
étaient d'ailleurs pour ça que notre
compétence et notre île nous sommes au
fait est que le texte s'appuie sur de
cette nouvelle compétence sur la loi
relative aux principes républicains
parce que c'est là aussi c'est un vrai
fléau les discours de haine
donc on avait dans le cadre de la loi de
la députée laetitia via créer un
observatoire de lutte contre la haine en
ligne qui existent toujours sur lequel
effectivement on réfléchit enfin on a
beaucoup beaucoup travailler au delà de
réfléchir on a beaucoup travaillé
notamment sur la définition sd d'un
discours de haine sur quels outils m à
mettre en place au niveau juridique mais
aussi dans le cadre d'éducation aux
médias
parce que le discours de haine enfin il
n'y a qu'un pas vers le harcèlement le
cyberharcèlement enfin
donc évidemment que ça nous préoccupe et
que quand on demande aux sites de là
aussi de
créer des outils
permettant d'endiguer
les discours de haine est par ailleurs
la désinformation on s'intéresse
évidemment au contenu donc on n'est pas
insensible à ce qui
à ce qu'il dit on est aussi attaché à ce
que le rgpp et appliquent c'est à dire
que les toutes ces plateformes avant la
plupart ne sont pas accessibles aux
mineurs il faut avoir 13 ans voire plus
même sur des boucles comme moi de
simples ses 16 ans donc là aussi
faire en sorte que la loi s'applique
le rappelait aussi aux parents que
effectivement n'inscrit pas son enfant
sur une plateforme sur un réseau social
à 8 ans
est par ailleurs pour en revenir à ces
entreprises qui créent des outils qui
sont en train de développer un outil
pour deux pour empêcher les mineurs
d'accéder aux sites pornographiques
elle a réfléchi soit pas uniquement à ça
elles réfléchissent aussi à faire en
sorte que les mineurs n'est pas plus
accès à ces plateformes parce
qu'effectivement l'écocité questionnaire
qu'elle pose au départ elle vous demande
effectivement sur ces réseaux sociaux
quel âge vous avez il est facile de
mentir sur son âge et personne ne
viendra s'en inquiéter mais là aussi il
est beau il est proposé de
que c'est c'est une nouvelle application
ou logiciels permettent aussi de
s'assurer de cela mais là aussi avec la
question des données qui est importante
puisque
les données des mineurs on doit aussi
s'assurer qu'elles ne soient pas captés
par par des entreprises qui ne devrait
pas le faire
voilà peut-être que j'ai oublié d
[Musique]
là moi j'allais au delà des démineurs
j'allais sur les adultes
les images qui font kiki qui favorise le
racisme les images où le titre est
explicite viol viol collectif ça
objectivement qu'on soit adulte aux
mineurs on n'a pas à voir ça mais
surtout on n'a pas à le mettre en ligne
alors encore moins à le faire mais
puisque là on est en train d'accepter de
visionner un crime non alors
oui non alors pour ces contenus
illicites enfin c'est simple ils sont
enfin ils sont supprimées il ya une
plateforme qui s'appelle pharos qui la
lutte contre les contenus que vous
décrivez qui eux sont supprimés
automatiquement donc non et les
plateformes aujourd'hui quand on est
nous sur le systémique on est plus sur
ce niveau on est sur un niveau plus
subtile d'appel à la haine c'est parfois
une insulte à une personnalité publique
ou politique avec qui on serait en
désaccord
mais effectivement ce que vous décrivez
madame mince et enfin pénalement c'est
répréhensible et donc évidemment les
plateformes doivent supprimer
ces contenus mais la masse est telle que
nous ce sûr qu'on travaille c'est leur
dire qu'effectivement elles peuvent pas
faire de la rue humaine elles nous
disent on n'a pas les moyens humains de
passer en vue de nez contenu il
développe une développe des outils
d'intelligence artificielle qui le font
mais nous on s'assure que ces outils
nains
2 soit bien calibré pour repérer les
contenus pose un problème et s'assurer
que quand on a on parfois on vous
demande si vous voulez signaler un
contenu bien que ce soit pas une
bouteille à la mer et que quelqu'un vous
répondez qui est que les choses soient
faites dans des temps plus que
raisonnable donc c'est donc le retard
répond en fait à 20h apparent vocation
bien évidemment on n'est pas passif face
à cela et d'ailleurs la loi ne l'est pas
puisque
toutes ses fins que ce soit des vidéos
d'appel au terrorisme de
pédopornographie enfin d'appel à la
haine d'appel au meurtre bien évidemment
son nom pas figurer sur cette plateforme
est d'ailleurs dans leurs conditions
générales d'utilisation
les plateformes enfin on les a passé en
revue elles ne doivent pas
ll ne elles mais elles ne le peuvent pas
et elles disent qu'elles n'ont pas ce
type 2
elle supprime ces sites puisqu'ils ne
sont pas en conformité avec la loi enfin
on ne peut pas avoir sur son
que s'agit de danse des informations ou
d'appels à la haine c'est très clair
si à écouter madame bien aimé je vous
remercie pour cette audition je crois
qu'il ya plus de demandes de paroles de
mes collègues et à la fois en visio et
et en présentiel ce qu'on aura vu ce
matin et pu constater c'est que bien
évidemment ni le législateur ni le csa
et l'hadopi fusionner en art comme nous
sont là pour jouer le rôle de censeur la
seule chose c'est que les contenus
pornographiques vont bien au delà de ce
qui est acceptable dans toutes les
autres sphères de la société
et c'est pour ça que nous veillions avec
cette nuit cette mission à vie
sexuels mais aussi je
disais que j'avais mis film violent
sexuel trois mots sur google est
immédiatement propose film violent
complet sexuelle vidéos pornos et sexe
âge et gratuite très bien j'ai eu besoin
de huit ans mais soigné non mais ça
effectivement chers collègues c'est ce
qui nous a été exposée et re exposées la
semaine dernière lors d'une audition est
très poignante et très difficile des
associations comme je lé dire en privé
dans mes propos liminaire donc
aujourd'hui millar comme ni légiste le
législateur ne souhaite se poser en
censeur
la seule chose c'est qu'on le voit bien
et les contenus sont extrêmement faciles
d'accès les contenus sont souvent d'une
grande violence et bien entendu vous
avez une mission qui vous a été alloué
sauf que je crois véritablement que les
moyens qui sont mis en face ne sont pas
à la hauteur de l'enjeu on parle de
millions de vues on parle de millions de
personnes qui vision qui visionnent ces
vidéos chaque mois les associations
les associations font un travail
fabuleux les pouvoirs publics semblent
assez
submergées donc nous la conclusion de
cette audition je pense c'est qu'on
n'est pas dotée aujourd'hui des outils
pour lutter contre cette pornographie
criminelle de grande ampleur qui est une
industrie on vous avait évoqué la
plateforme pharos
évidemment et on parle de millions de vu
des millions de vues donc si on n'a pas
les moyens d'actionner d'aider des
personnes qui vont identifier ses vues
jamais on arrivera à les supprimer donc
il ya ce probable premier problème les
associations elles font un travail
formidable de terrain elle non plus
elles ne seront pas capacité de
visionner tous ces films parce que on
l'a vu la semaine dernière visionner ses
films c'est aussi se confronter à une
barbarie est une horreur
extrêmement poignante et certaines
personnes que nous avons auditionné
disait en faire des cauchemars
régulièrement parce que ces images sont
d'une violence inimaginable
et puis vous avez l'art comme l'art
comme qui remplit sa mission votre
mission à l'ewi de contrôler l'accès des
mineures mais je ne suis pas persuadé à
l'issue de cette audition que vous ayez
véritablement les moyens de contrôler
l'accès parce que l'on ne peut pas se
cacher sur juste contrôler l'accès et
mes collègues l'ont évoqué les images
qui sont proposés à la fois sur le
numérique et sur le média télévisuel ne
sont pas acceptables on ne pourront
n'accepterait pas cela du notre
industrie est ce qu'on acceptera cela
d'une autre industrie non donc il ya un
vrai problème d'acceptation de la
violence dans la pornographie
aujourd'hui et bah écoutez nous sommes
au début d'un cycle d'auditions nous
vous remercions sincèrement d'être venu
répondre à nos questions et on sera
assez vigilant sur l'application aussi
de la loi parce que même si les décrets
mettre beaucoup de temps à sortir ce
qu'il n'est pas nouveau une fois qu'ils
sont sortis ils doivent être appliquées
sur merci à toutes et à tous pour cette
participation et nous allons poursuivre
nos travaux merci madame bien aimé merci
à vous mesdames d'avoir accompagné van
hamme bien aimé dans cette audition de
ce matin
[Musique]